so
hello you're watching entertainment week
coming up on the show we're joined by
the star of the oscar-nominated film
selma david o'yellow jessica chastain on
defying stereotypes in her new crime
drama a most violent year from ramsey
street to the palace jason donovan tells
us about his role in the king's speech
and johnny depp on playing a
crime-fighting english gent in mordecai
first let's catch up on all the week's
entertainment news there is flash
photography coming up
coronation street actress ann kirk bride
died following a short illness age 60
she played deidre barlow for over 40
years alongside actor william roach even
in the midst of shouting and crying
there will be a laugh that's what she
was about annie she loved life topshop
lost its legal battle against rihanna
over the use of an unapproved image on a
t-shirt james blunt branded the shadow
culture minister chris bryant a
classless after he used the
singer's privileged background as an
example of a lack of diversity in the
arts an israeli man has been arrested on
suspicion of hacking into madonna's
computer and selling her unreleased
songs online she described the leak as a
devastating and hurtful experience and
bjork was the latest artist forced into
rush releasing her new album after it
was leaked two months ahead of schedule
pharrell williams shared a stage with al
gore to announce a series of live earth
concerts which will be held in every
continent this june and oscar nominee
bradley cooper is coming to london's
west end in may with his broadway hit
the elephant man
now a defining moment in the civil
rights movement has become the subject
of one of the most talked about films of
the awards season selma is the story of
the epic marches through alabama that
led to equal voting rights in america
although the film secured a best picture
nomination at the oscars the academy has
drawn criticism for overlooking british
actor david oyelowo for his
career-defining performance as martin
luther king we spoke to him ahead of
those nominations
there have been thousands of racially
motivated murders
we need your help dr king this thing's
just gonna have to wait it cannot wait
you got one big issue i got a hundred
one somewhere it is
here is the next great battle david is
so lovely to see you thank you so much
for coming in thank you now this this is
a part of a lifetime isn't it yeah it is
it is um
it's it's very rare that you are in a
moment in your career where you
absolutely know that this is going to be
one of the highlights no matter what
comes
beyond this moment and uh you know i i
think for me this this is definitely the
case with this role and a part that you
heard about quite a few years ago read
the parts
seven years until you actually played it
how did that make you feel were you
anxious was it stressful did you think
about this role every day
um i did actually um uh not least
because i
when i first read it my uh connection to
it was a very spiritual one i felt
called to do it and the reason i say
that is because
you know when i first read it it was
soon after moving to the states and so
i hadn't done any hollywood films i'm
british so you know playing dr king is
not
something i would even cast myself as
doing at that stage but it because i
just knew so deep in my spirit that this
was something that was going to happen
um that's where the journey began and
now seven years in i didn't know it was
going to take that long it's just so
gratifying that it actually happened
so when you got the part apart from
being hugely elated i think relief that
that period of uncertainty was over
not just relief but also just i've been
in awe at the timing of the film because
you know like i said i i i first read it
in 2007 i was actually cast in 2010 by
the director who was attached at the
time lee daniels and then we still
couldn't get the film off the ground but
in the intervening
time since first reading and now i did
films like lincoln the butler the help
and
red tails as well all of which chart
150 years of what it is to be black in
america
uh and as someone who's not from that
culture it all went into
this film and playing dr king and then
you think of what's been going on in
america recently in terms of race
relations and renewed protests and you
know this just feels like there's
something divine in terms of the timing
of it all yeah i mean it does feel so
timely with the events
over in america and how difficult has
that made it or how pertinent
um it hasn't made it difficult in some
ways it's a shame that
um
selma feels
not like a historical drama almost feels
like it's ripped from the headlines but
this actually happened 50 years ago the
thing that i i'm very
gratified about is that you know we set
out to make a film that feels relevant
that feels immediate that is propulsive
in terms of the filmmaking and um
we
wrapped the film in third on the third
of july uh michael brown was murdered on
the 9th of august um the eric ghana
situation has happened more recently and
you know we've seen the the protests as
well going on so a lot of things have
happened since shooting the film that
have made it feel more relevant but we
set out to make a film that feels
relevant anyway so it's almost like of
the film and the time it was made for a
sort of meeting in the middle and at the
premiere you all want i can't breathe
t-shirts to protest against the death of
eric garner and that's quite rare that a
film
cast and crew would stand up like that
and make it make it a statement it's
quite a bold move in some ways did you
feel that
um yes but you know
in in many ways
um having
spent time uh looking at dr king and
that movement and what they did at the
time they did it you know one of the
things that i i've been so inspired by
is harry belafonte sydney poitier nina
simone sammy davis jr these were all
people who were incredible entertainers
but they were socially engaged in terms
of what was going on in their day and i
do think there's been a degree of apathy
generally
both
the public in general and and performers
who
you know whether it's wrong or right um
you are given a bit of a platform and i
think if you have
something meaningful to say use the
platform to do that and i think that you
know that that gesture was part part of
that really and does it depress you that
you're having to make gestures like this
and that race relations are still such a
massive issue
here
particularly in the states at the moment
well
yeah it is disheartening um but having
said that there are very clear
discernible
uh evidences of huge change you know i
mean of course uh barack obama
symbolizes that oprah winfrey who is a
producer on the film and is in the movie
as well and is one of the main reasons
this film got made is evidence of that
eva duvernay uh you know the first
black woman to be nominated for a golden
globe and has done incredible work on
this film i think you know is evidence
of of how things have changed as well
but
you know the one of the reasons i'm so
glad selma exists as a film is i think
that
we could and especially young people
could think that
the world we're currently living in is
one in which there's this new thing
there's this new racial tension and here
we are protesting it's not a new thing
you know it happened 50 years ago
the difference back then is you had
leadership
and you had you know people who were
able to articulate the needs uh of
people uh you know being a voice to the
voiceless in the corridors of power and
you know as as is seen in selma that
brought about change relatively quickly
you know the summer campaign was from uh
january to march of 1965 the law had
changed by august of 1965 my hope is
that
the film is evidence of an inspiration
to
uh bring about change now
um as we've been talking about race
relations is an issue over in the states
at the moment is here it's also an issue
in hollywood chris rock recently wrote
an essay saying that hollywood is a
white industry
do you think that's fair is that
something that you've experienced
i think look
part of the reason
selma took so long to make
is because up until recently the idea of
uh black protagonists in the center of
their own narrative in terms of films of
this nature historical films
ha they've mostly been told through the
eyes of white characters it isn't until
uh films like the butler and 12 years a
slave came along and did very well
critically and at the box office
that you know we're seeing a little bit
of a sea change i know for a fact that
selma i was a beneficiary of those two
films doing what they did i think the
truth of the matter is that
um
we all want to see ourselves in movies
and if the people who have green light
power are or a certain section of
society that's what you see on screen
it's a reflection of the people who have
the power to say yes and so i just think
we just need to diversify that
because it seems quite unbelievable that
this story martin luther king's story
hasn't been told more prominently in
hollywood before i mean
what luck for you
i know you know there's a part of me
that's very annoyed at the fact that
it's taking so long there's a part of me
that's very relieved because it probably
wouldn't have been me if it had happened
sooner so um so yeah it is it is kind of
crazy but i'm i'm so happy that it's
happened now and i truly
feel like you know we have
given the world a film that doesn't just
accentuate his reputation as an icon but
shows you the man behind the historical
figure and like i say we go to the
movies to see ourselves if we can see a
little piece of ourselves in dr king i
think that can only be a good thing
lots of awards season buzz around this
how important is that to you how
exciting is it
it's definitely exciting important well
you know
it does bring attention to the film it
does make people want to see the film so
from that point of view it's significant
and fantastic also as an actor it's a
very subjective profession you you tend
to not really know that you're a good
actor unless people tell you fantastic
well good luck with it all thank you so
much for joining us david thank you
thank you very much
and it's been a busy time for david he
also stars in the crime drama a most
violent year his co-star jessica
chastain earned a golden globe
nomination for her role as one half of a
couple drawn into the underworld of 80s
new york she spoke to skies hannah stott
my husband
is not my father
not even close
so if i were you
i would start treating us with a little
more respect or i guarantee
he will make it his mission in life
to ruin you
what i really like about this film is
it's the
anti-gangster morality tale i mean even
though it being called the most violent
year even looking at like the look of
the
film oscar of course is reminiscent of
al pacino and the godfather just by the
way he looks and he's playing you know
an immigrant coming to the united states
and
trying to be successful to have the
american dream the thing that i like the
most to me is that the wife
character is more than a
wife she's i in my opinion she's like
dick cheney
she
in the partnership she allows her
husband to to be the face of the
organization and she does some
underhanded things on the side while
keeping him ignorant to it let's talk
about you getting oscar isaac this role
because he pretty much worked as his
agent did you get a car i think he did
no
well to be honest i i feel like i did jc
a great service especially after seeing
the being on set and seeing oscar's
performance he's so good in this and he
and i went to college together we've
known each other for over 13 years this
was a situation where it just was so
it's like it was perfect late perfectly
laid out um originally it was going to
be another actor and when that actor
fell through i said jc you know
i know someone who is really right for
this part just quickly about the oscars
you had four big films out all
critically acclaimed great films do you
feel any sense of disappointment for not
getting a nomination this time oh
absolutely not i mean interstellar i
think got five nominations i'm not sure
i'm very proud of that film
um the most violent year is
i've gotten nominated for golden globe
and um
it's on like all the you know the best
critics lists and it's really exciting
it's um one of the best reviewed films
in the united states which is pretty
great because it's an incredible season
um
so no i mean to me that that whole thing
it's a formula i don't understand
but it's i've had a really incredible
few years and
to at the end of the day to be in a film
like this with my friend oscar with a
filmmaker jc who i know is going to have
the longest most beautiful career and
the film turn out great i'm happy
and coming up is johnny out of his depth
we'll be reviewing the comedy caper
mordecai
four years ago the king's speech
dominated the awards season and became
the most successful independent british
film ever at the uk box office but it
was originally written as a play and
this year it's being brought back to the
stage to tour the uk taking up the roles
of king george and his speech therapist
lionel logue are raymond coulthard and
jason donovan who join me now great to
see you both
now this was such a phenomenal success
on screen is there massive amounts of
pressure now jason for you to do well in
this play i i guess i feel pressure with
anything you do particularly when it's
you know uh it's it has such a great
history like this piece does
um
but you know i i'd apply
you know the the effort i would into
something like this as i would into any
piece of work i do and you know try and
give it a 100 percent um
you know i mean i i guess i'm quite
lucky with with this role in the sense
that that he's an australian so that
that's uh
yeah i mean if they start criticizing me
about my accent then i'm i'm gonna have
something to say about that and what are
the advantages of of telling a story
like this on stage as opposed to on film
well i think that a piece started life
as a as a play
in fact i i i hear that david seidler
who was the original writer of the piece
and actually i believe won the academy
award for the screenplay wrote to the
queen mother before putting the piece
together and she
refused
his
invitation to have it uh written but of
course since she passed um the uh it it
then became a script
i you know i i think it reads so well as
a play you know it well interestingly i
think i think with the film i think they
cut out
they changed it quite considerably from
the place so it is people coming to see
it who have seen the film i think are
seeing something very different
which is good i think there's a there's
a big political backdrop to the play
which was sort of hinted at in the film
but inevitably i think because of the
nature of film i think they concentrated
more on the
on those sort of small domestic scenes
jason you've done loads of theater over
the last few years is that where you now
feel most at home
i seem to age well with you
that's
um
i don't know i don't think he's very
nice it's it's it's it's chosen me it's
it's not necessarily been the course
that i've thought about you know and
particularly musicals i mean this is a
sort of a break from that for me and i'm
i'm really welcoming that with open arms
i you know i i love the musicals but i
my uh background is really sort of in
acting and i feel most comfortable as an
actor um
but yeah no i'm i think we're we're
we're excited about this piece i think
it's time for it
you know and i think it's a very
historic piece i think it has an
educational aspect to it i think it's
great entertainment
um you know and i and and and i think
it's going to be a success let's yeah
and that's true though i think that has
been long enough now
since the film and of course a
production was done of it
um a theater production and i think
there's been enough time to revisit it
actually
so yeah i'm really looking forward to it
jason i can't let you go without asking
30 years of neighbours this year is
there anything that could be done to
tempt you back no
i get asked this a lot i'm you know i'm
very proud of neighbours and there is
not a day goes by in my life that that i
don't really refer back to it
professionally
ask me about and that's cool i i get
that but you know in terms of going back
it's sort of you know that was then i
think if everybody went back it would
probably make it interesting but you
can't have sort of
you know pieces enough's enough yeah
enough so thank you both so much tell us
when does the play start and where
the fifth of february is opening night
in chichester amazing good luck with it
thank you so much thank you yes thank
you time to see what's on at the cinema
this weekend and there's yet another
quirky character from johnny depp
i am lord charlie mordecai
respected by all who know me
slightly
man down
i am an art dealer an aficionado
my wife joanna
my only true love i thought i'd see how
you secret agent men run the world i'm
afraid i shall have to put my foot down
darling sorry what's your permission of
course
and our film critic joe joins me now joe
so one review i've read is poster awful
premise awful quite a lot is awful about
this film oh they're really that there
is a lot awful in this film but it's not
all awful i think that's probably going
uh slightly too far i mean it's very
much sort of a substance carry-on movie
you know this is johnny depp's baby
really in many respects and he's clear
he relishes playing the sort of the cad
the bounder the moustache twirling sort
of aristocratic idiot and you know when
you think back to his last performance
and transcendence where he literally was
dead behind the eyes at least he looks
vaguely half alive in this movie
strange choices very strange choices but
i think there will potentially be a
market for this i mean it's it is that
kind of sort of 1970s you know if you
find accents funny and sexually innuendo
funny and all that kind of stuff all
you're sitting on my bonnet and you know
all this kind of stuff you it's the film
for you and you know when i spoke to
johnny depp i did sort of say you know
it seems to be have lots of british
influences from the 1970s
i didn't go back and watch any of those
films
for fear of you know gleaning some
personality trait that you really
shouldn't have for this character so
they were based on
my memories really of of those films and
and and those uh
those incredible kind of uh
caper uh films that existed back then
and were cool and this is that's what
this is
it's all the most animated i've ever
seen him in that interview i actually
walked into that room with a haze of
e-vape cigarette smoke whatever that
vaping stuff is so yeah he's uh he's a
chilled out kind of guy he still pulls
off the sunglasses doesn't he ex machina
is next so this is oscar isaac's alicia
vakande who we had on
everywhere a testament of youth and we
fell out massively about and i haven't
seen this one so i can't disagree with
you what's it like
um it's sort of proper grown-up adult
sci-fi it's a bit sort of a
claustrophobic psychological thriller
very much like a chamber play as well
sort of just three of them in it okay
let's have a look
do you have a name
yes
ava
i'm pleased to meet you ava
i'm pleased to meet you too
do you know what the touring test is so
that's alyssia vacanza looking slightly
less beautiful than she did
if you can pull off that look you know
good looking you know the film hinges on
those uh scenes there between donald
gleason and alicia vikander he's taking
the turing test which you know he's
trying to see if he can work out that if
she has if he can work out she's a robot
and it's alex garland yeah from who
wrote the beach that directed and 28
days later and you can tell he's a
writer as well because every scene has
this cliffhanger in many respects it's
almost like a soap opera and it kind of
sucks you in and gets tighter and
tighter thrilling finale
finale yeah i did like it you know it's
one of those films you have to settle
down and really put your mind to you
can't sort of be flicking through your
ipad or reading the paper while you're
watching it but yeah it's worth a look
but you know it's sort of
proper adult sci-fi this isn't guardians
of the galaxy this is the best science
fiction really makes you think oscar
isaacs is also in our next film a most
violent year and um david o yellow and
we heard from jessica chastain
we've had them all and this hasn't been
oscar nominated and jessica earlier was
saying that she couldn't quite work out
what got nominated what didn't what the
game was i mean do you agree is it
something that should have got
amendments there's been lots of chat
isn't there there's all these there's
always sort of films oscar buzz and
build up and sometimes they don't come
through you know selma or david yellow
was the other one we're all talking
about but you know when you look at the
categories this year i think jessica
chastain
potentially really should have had an
oscar nod it's not the strongest year
for female roles is it but you know like
she said herself it's no rhyme or reason
between these things she didn't get the
nod and we move on lucy well she didn't
look too distraught did she thank you so
much
next year maybe and that is all for now
coming up on next week's show
oscar-winning director stephen dawdry
talks trash his bafta nominated foreign
language film and star of the killing
sophie grabol tells us about her
chilling new drama fortitude see you
then